[Cool Anime Intro + MUSIC]
(Caramell - Caramelldansen)
(Voah Vicky Edited)
STOP!! STOP THAT SH*T NOW!
I LOVE EVERYBODY!
i LOVE YOU!
こんにちは
(Hello in Japanese)
はじめまして
(Nice to meet you in Japanese)
フェリックスさんです
(I am Felix in Japanese)
As you can tell after my trip in japan,
I have learned some awesome
level of anime skill.
すごい です ね
(It's amazing in Japanese)
But with great power
comes great responsibility.
And I have finally learned what that means.
The legendary anime creator
Hayao Miyazaki
*Yeah, that's 100% him*
Said "Anime was a mistake."
*That is actually Hayao*
And now I finally understand his sentiment. (wow poods)
I finally understand what he meant.
*SOME WEIRD ANIME STUFF*
*keeps muttering some sh*t*
(TORNADOOOOOOOOOO)
IM YELLING IN JAPANESE
*WTF*
*SWIRLS AND SWIRLS*
STAHP. Stahp it right now. I Love Everybody! (woahvicky poods)
See what I'm talking about? Anime was a mistake.
What anime was this, by the way? (Poods is a true ass man)
So, let's together examine some of the worst examples of anime victims.
Any of these *giggle* that we are about to watch... could've been me, okay?
I feel their pain.
*PREPARE FOR UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF CRINGE*
(knocks the door)
Girl: Happy Birthday, Aitor! *giggles*
(Dude creamed his pants)
#Soyboy
*Pewds is jealous but hides it under his scorn*
Ooh... *touched* I've seen this one, but it's so beautiful!  *inner weeb comes out*
He's so sweet!
(pewds keeps laughing)
... my god...
Pewds: Oh, oh..
Narrator: Aitor loves to collect things from Japan.
Pewds: Oh, does he?
(Remind you of anyone?)
I see he's a man of culture, wow....
*inner shame intensifies*
It's practically my room! Ha ha!
*Pewds can't tell whether to cry or cringe*
*Pewds can feel this man's inner sorrow*
*You will be ashamed of your words and deeds*
I can't! I can't...
Look at the old man in the background wh-w-wha?
Aaw, they're so supportive...
*Bunch of degenerates*
*Wheeze* It's too wholesome, I can't! Aaw...
It's like they don't get it at all and...
... probably they won't, but at the same time they get that he's on TV and for a reason so they think it's like... ugh.
In a different universe this is me, it's ... *giggles more*
Oh my god, what is this?
*UNPRECEDENTED CRINGE INTENSIFIES*
*Pewds cannot stand the Attack on Titan normie shit going on here*
*Can't take it anymore*
*triggered* Jesus Christ...
You guy know, there are other animes out there?
Eh-everythin-every time. Every single time, it's always...
...Attack on Titan, like it's the only anime that exists.
Pewds 12-year-old voice: BuT Th3y'r3 $0 cu73 1n th3 an1m3!
1 l0v3 L3v1, h3's s0 kawai11!
*Pewd's soul continues to crumble*
*This is the face of a man who is dying inside, look what anime has done to our Poodie!*
*Seriously, I love AOT, but even I cannot stand to watch this*
*Pewds plots communist overthrow of the anime world*
I can't watch this... it makes me sick.
Rachel Dolezal: A hard time I've been going through is...
...deciding whether or not I'm Japanese.
Pewds: What?
VickyWoahMkII: Don't, like, people are gonna judge me for this. I'm aware of that.
But, like I feel it in my veins, I know who I am and I think I'm Japanse.
Pewds: She thinks she's Japanese.
WoahhVicky has got... she's got some competition it seems like. *laughs*
Okay, what's the motivation behind this conclusion? *prepare yourselves*
Idiot: Like, recently I've been, like, reading lots of maine-uh...
BISH SE WHAT?
*Pewds laughs*
Pewds FanPerson voice: R3c3nt1y, 1'v3 b33n r3ad1ng l0ts 0f manga, and n0w 1 turn 1nt0 Japan3s3 p3rs0n!
1 just f33l s0 par7 0f 7h31r cultur3 n0w!!
*Whatever you say, nutjob*
Oh, that reminds me of the "Girugamesh"
*That's an "Engrish" pronunciation of Gilgamesh and the name of a metal band*
Funny voices: Girugamesh and manga!"
*This is the Sakura-con 2009 commercial meme*
Person 1: I love sushi.
Person 2: I love Japan period
*People agreeing*
Kid: J-Rock!
Japanese metalhead: Girugamesh!
People: Aw yeah!
Fat person: I love anime!
Random chick: And manga!
Person 4: GAMING! (BASS BOOSTED)
*This got out of hand*
*wheezing, giggling, laughter*
AND GAMING! HAHA!
*Admit it Poods, you're just as much of a weeb as those sickos*
Crazy Bach: Like I also really like their food like sushi...
Pewds: Oh, sushi, man.
Crazy person: All that kind of stuff.
Pewds: Have you heard about this?
Have you heard about this? They put raw fish!
*What IS this?*
(Whispers) Jesus Christ...
How? What is it with anime that just draws them out?
I'm not sure if it's drawing them out, or if it's transforming people to this...
... despicable disgusting form.
Dude: One... now...
*I can tell this is a sociopath*
♪ >Aitteke< no yume wo kakiatsume ♪ (Wrong Lyrics)
*Pewds wheezes, laughing*
♪ Sagashimono wo sagashi *ni* yuku no sa~~ ♪
*Clap clap: MEME REVIEW!*
Dude: One piece!
*Pewds dying, can't breath*
It's a dead face, and this-the monotone singing. This is beautiful. I love it what what a great talent.
*Pewds' EP of the same theme song, but dead inside himself*
GAMING! ( BASS BOOSTED AGAIN)
It's not nearly as good as his, I'm sorry for even trying.
Okay.
*Psycho sings happy birthday song*
Psycho: Happy birthday, Kotonoha...
Pewds: Oh... :(
Pyscho: Happy birthday to youuuu!
Pyscho: Blow up the candles Kotonoha!
Pewds: Yeah, blow out the candles, do it.
Dude blows out candles: YAAAAY!
Hey, wait a minute, that...
... That wasn't Kotonoha blowing out those candles.
*Oh really?*
Anchor: Kairo seijuro wasn't looking for trouble...
Pewds: Oh my god!
Yes, I forgot about this clip!  th-this is the best! *Laughs*
Pewds: Sorry, okay, let's just watch.
Reporter: ..that night the trouble certainly found him when that fight broke out
He was ready for us with his trusty katana
Pewds: Yes!
Kairo: I actually carry this because I become a little bit more dangerous without it than with it .
So it's more of a restraint mechanism than a safety plan
0_0
He's-he's carrying around a katana so that he will restrain himself. Because he's "more dangerous without it."
*Of COURSE*
Reporter: The fight had been going on for about 20 minutes
It was two-on-one, but none of them saw Kairo Seijuro move around behind them.
Kairo: to them, they probably thought I was just moving out of the way.
*Pewds is dying again*
But I was actually setting up to where their blind spot was. If he had gone on me, I would have-
He was setting up the blind spot!
You were in a tram, there was nowhere else to be!
Loony: Drop the sword down and then completely cut and completely cave him open. This actually says that they weren't even a challenge.
Pewds: Jesus!
I already had a pul-uh-a full five stage plan ready to take everyone out
"Five stage plan," huh? Damn, that's not bad.
That's the way of the samurai; you got to think ahead. Always have a plan.
Kairo: and anybody else you got involved just in case.
*whoa, WHAT?!*
He was ready to kill anyone else joining in. Oh my god...
*He wants to join in but the anime has corrupted his soul*
*This is some Jabbawockeez-level synch right here*
If there's one song in the whole universe that will trigger me more than anything, it's that intro song.
I used to know the whole dance.
*Oh DID you?"
*Wait, I thought you said you USED TO!*
♪ Nani mo nani mo mada shiranu ♪ (Broken Japanese)
(This is Straight Outta Naruto*
♪ udatte udatte udatteku ♪ (Broken Japanese)
Pewds: Oh, wow.
♪ >koremaku< ase ga ♪ (Wrong Lyrics)
♪ koboreru no sa ♪ (Monotone)
♪ obetini (inaudible) ♪ (Wrong Lyrics)
♪ (inaudible) ~roh ♪
*Pewds can't take it anymore*
If you're gonna sing anime, at least get the right pitch! At least get the right tone!
At least get something right about it!
I don't even care if he's meming this... I-i-it's bad. This is bad, and you should be ashamed of yourself.
It's a wonderful song, and you completely ruined it for me and for everyone!
This is why anime was a mistake and I hope you've learned your lesson.
*I have, I am scarred by this video*
Leave a like If you enjoy anime, leave it like if you...
... lose?
*You laugh, you anime everybody!*
♪ Rashinban Nante Jutai No Moto, Netsu Ni ♪
♪ Ukasare Kaji Wo Toru No Sa
Hokori Kabutteta ♪
*MrEvan312 helped contribute subs. Leave a like if you subs, subscribe if you dubs*
GAMING (Bass Boost)
WHY are y'all still here?!